[موسيقى]
الدائره العظيمه خطها يصبح مستقيما اذا
اقتطعنا جزءا يسيرا منه والارض مكونه من
خطوط الطول ودوائر العرض سميت خطا بناء
على الجزء اليسير فهو مستقيما مسطحا والى
الارض كيف سطحت وسميت دائره بناء على
حجمها الكلي الكروي يكور الليل على النهار
ويكور النهار على الليل ودوائر العرض هي
خطوط او دوائر وهميه عددها 180 90 دائره
شمال خط الاستواء وتسعين دائره جنوب خط
الاستواء والشمس تتعامد على ثلاثه خطوط
منها على خط الاستواء ومدار سرطان ومدار
الجدي تتيه الشمس والعمر المنير اذا قلنا
كانكما الامير لان الشمس تغرب حين تمسي
وان البدر ينقصه
المسير
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ولدوائر العرض فوائد منها تحديدا المناطق
الحراريه على الارض وهي المناطق الواقعه
على مدار السرطان ومدار الجديد تحديد
المواقع الجغرافيه عليها بما يسمى بنظام
الاحداثيات ونظام الاحداثيات نبع من تخيل
الاغريق لشكل الارض قبل الفين سنه واول من
ترجمها على الواقع هما الرومان واول من
قاس المسافه بين خط الى خط اخر هم العرب
عن طريق ارتفاع الناجم القطبي نجم النجوم
اللي بنوره تهاديت بقطع الظلام اللي يخوف
مهده اطيب نجم لا صار يمه تلديت وقتها نجم
لا صار وجهك تلده
[موسيقى]